cette norme il est temps que la société
prenne sa revanche par l'organe puissant
mais je n'ai reconnu des peintures
général de la république des proches
française
[Musique]
merci rabaul ses choix est indicatif
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés cher maîtresse
madame la chanteuse ex surréaliste néo
des boulonnaises de statut public chéri
mon amour si tu t'imagines juliette
juliette
si tu t'imagines que je vais requérir
contre toi après tout ce qui va se
passer entre nous ce que tu te goures
juliette juliette ce que tu te goures je
suis vraiment désolé monsieur le
président je n'ai aucune agressivité à
l'encontre de l'accusé et juliette gréco
j'en demande pardon à la défense puisque
en accusant pas l'accusé jean piette en
quelque sorte sur son territoire
pardonnez-moi firme ariane 6 le piétine
ainsi vos bandes
oui je vis
à la lan79 ma poule du mexique justement
je dis vos bandes mais j'ai pas dis
platz innovex pascal maria n'aime pas
qu'on parle de son buste exact n'ayant
rien à dire vais-je la fermer pour
autant que les nih ce serait mal me
connaître
vais-je alors parler de quelque chose
d'intéressant cette fois noël mais pour
la cl point que je lis une fois de plus
quelques angoisses dans l'oeil est
magnifique et bordée de très beaux s'il
d'un beau brun roux de notre cher
président il se l'est fait que je dis ça
il se fait que les bateaux
je sais ce que vous pensez monsieur le
président vous ne pouvez rien de caché
vous pensez j'espère que cet imbécile
c'est moi j'espère que c'est un v6 il ne
va tout de même pas nous lire une fois
de plus le courrier des auditeurs
tiens je vais me gêner en effet cheikh
auditeurs j'ai en main alors je vous
parle
devinez quoi j'ai en main la lettre
d'une fidèle auditrice madame chantal la
terrasse situe c'est vrai c'est pas bien
kim écrit je cite la lettre ferme chez
des proches
j'aimerais tellement vous rencontrez une
bonne 1re votre talent
en fait c'est énorme sonne bien que je
vous lis pas tout avant votre formation
rien que tous les deux ne la robe passé
austère que ça ni nadia à voilà le
tribunal des flagrants délires est fait
par des cons pour des cons cher monsieur
des proches qu'est ce qu'un conte
comment reconnaît-on un vrai con d'info
vous êtes bien placé pour savoir qu'à ce
moment s'il vous plaît répondez moi si
vous voulez me tenir un jour dans vos
bras 6 juin mes photos signées chantal
et j'ai cette photo sur les yeux je dois
dire madame c'est un excellent croupion
je vous remercie de l'avoir proposé est
maintenant venons en au conte comment
reconnaître un con c'est vrai que c'est
une bonne question
le mot qu'on appartient à la langue
française et à elle seule
aucune langue étrangère ne peut se
flatter de posséder un mot tout à fait
équivalent du beau conte cette carence
grammaticales est d'autant plus
surprenante que nous le savons depuis
toujours
les étrangers sont tous des cons y at il
des clubs de cons bien sûr
retournez vous pas vous retournez vous
si vous êtes seul un simple miroir de
poche fera la faire si vous ne possédez
pas de miroir de poche
allez dans n'importe quelle
administration quand le préposé vous
demandera de remplir le formulaire ses
112 alinéa 18 déclamer lui 4 vers de
verlaine observer le bien il exprime
sous son front bas une sourde
consternation il a l'air con est ce à
dire que tous les préposés des guichets
administratifs sont des cons non ainsi
finalement existe-t-il des signes
extérieurs de conneries certes oui on
peut reconnaître un conte rien qu'à sa
façon de s'habiller
la caractéristique vestimentaire du
conte consiste en un besoin irrésistible
de s'habiller comme tout le monde
faites le test suivant vous prenez des
notes il m'était dix personnes dans une
pièce observez bien ces dix personnes
sur ces 10 personnes il y en a au moins
une qui est habillé comme les neuf
autres c'est un con ces scientifiques
quand 40 personnes s'habille comme un
con c'est l'académie française
quand mille personnes s'habille comme un
con c'est l'armée française
peut-on reconnaître un conte rien qu'à
sa démarche
oui la démarche d'un conte est très
caractéristique quoique fort difficile à
décrire par le seul moyen du vocabulaire
on peut cependant en un mot si l'on veut
bien m'excuser le manque de rigueur
scientifique de l'expression décrire la
démarche caractéristiques du conte en
disant que quand il part en direct qui
revient et les cons infirme direz vous
eh ben ils vont alors quelle différence
yat il maintenant entre un imbécile est
un con il existe une différence
essentielle entre l'imbécile locaux qui
tient en une seule formule d'une grande
simplicité
l'imbécile lee france dimanche le conte
écrit dans ici paris
[Applaudissements]
les comptes il bon moral
oui ils sont très contents de
l'évolution de la situation
internationale
les qu'on aime rire on ne rencontre
souvent dans les sous bois car il adore
les plaisanteries de derrière les fagots
l'optimisme du co au moyen fait plaisir
à voir par exemple les qu'on croit
vraiment que si la chemise de paul est
plus blanches de la chemise de jacques
c'est grâce à bercy en tire des
positions par ailleurs les cons après
rasage s'asperge avec brut de la jungle
pour nous les hommes brut de la jungle
autre façon d'être un conte comment
vivent les cons l'hiver les constats sur
des gradins et crie allez les verts le
fait de se tasser sur des gradins en
criant allez les verts est un signe
irréfutable de conneries d'autant que
cette année à mon avis c'est nantes qui
va gagner
les télés qu'on fonce tête baissée vers
les plages où il aime ta s'agglutiner
ensemble pour ne pas perdre une miette
de la chaleureuse promiscuité
immobilière de la ville
ils forment ainsi un conglomérat de
fourmies ténue et continue de calais à
hendaye et de port vendres à nice d'où
l'expression être un peu con sur les
bords
au printemps les cons ne vont pas chez
le coiffeur il retourne à lourdes
à l'automne les qu'on revienne de lourds
sauf ceux qui se sont noyés en
s'approchant trop près du manneken pis
les cons militaires sont ils plus
dangereux que les autres assure mme
hâtives
[Applaudissements]
ils sont féroces et pousse des cris de
bête
d'où l'expression entendez-vous dans nos
campagnes mugir ces treize soldats
oui c'est des cons y at-il dès qu'on
célèbre
ah oui hélas la liste on est beaucoup
trop longue et j'ai maintenant céder la
parole à la défense je citerai
simplement celui le qui à mon avis il
est le plus con des cons j'ai nommé le
célèbre mathématicien peu clide qui
affirmait sans rire et c'est encore
étudier actuellement dans les écoles
c'est un scandale
il disait clide la ligne droite est le
plus court chemin d'un point à un autre
quelle connerie chacun sait en effet que
la ligne droite ne peut-être le plus
court chemin d'un point à un autre
sauf évidemment si les deux points sont
en face l'un de l'autre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non